Hello I'm Daven Hiskey, you're watching the
Today I Found Out YouTube channel, in the
video today, we're looking at that time a
young Fyodor Dostoevsky was put in front of
a firing squad and thought he was going to
die.
On December 22, 1849, members of a Russian
intellectual literary group known as the Petrashevsky
Circle were sent to Semyonov Square to meet
their fate – death by firing squad.
With the men pointing their rifles and fingers
resting on the trigger, a messenger from the
Tsar rode into the square waving a white flag.
Like something out of a Hollywood movie, he
declared he had an official pardon from the
Tsar of Russia, Nicholas I, in a “show of
mercy.”
This was not a show of mercy, but rather a
staged way of fostering fear, terror, and
gratitude.
This was a “mock execution” and among
the victims was the famed Russian author of
Crime & Punishment, Fyodor Dostoevsky.
So how did he get here?
Fyodor Dostoevsky was born in November 1821
to a working class Russian family.
His father worked for a hospital catering
to the poor and, while his family was better
off than most, he saw first-hand the poverty
and disillusionment of Russian society during
the 19th century.
When he was a child, Fyodor’s father would
be promoted several times at the hospital,
while coming into possession of lands and
serfs.
This exposure to Russia’s system of serfdom
would greatly influence Dostoevsky later in
life.
By the time he had turned 18, both of his
parents had died; his mother from consumption
(see our video on Why Tuberculosis was Called
Consumption) and his father under more mysterious
circumstances.
While doctors said he died of a stroke, a
neighbor swore up and down that he was murdered
by his peasants, tied to a chair and drowned
in vodka.
In 1846, Dostoevsky published his first work
Poor Folk (also called Poor People), a novella
depicting the lives of poor Russians and their
relationships with the rich.
It was lauded as an achievement by critics,
newspapers, and the general literary community.
Read the Russian political newspaper Northern
Bee,
"News about a new genius, Mr. Dostoevsky,
is circulating across St. Petersburg.
We do not know whether it is his real name
or a pen-name.
The reading audience is praising his new novel,
Poor People."
Even the great Russian critic Vissarion Belinsky
praised the novel for being socially conscious
and written with great skill.
Taking Dostoevsky under his wing, he introduced
him to a number of Russian writers, poets,
and artists.
At least one Dostoevsky biographer believed
that this was not a good thing.
Said Dmitry Grigorovich, “I can say with
confidence that the success of Poor People,
as well as the admiration of Belinsky, definitely
had a negative influence on Dostoevsky.”
Grigorovich goes on to describe how Dostoevsky
became arrogant, insufferable, and too confident.
Only 15 days later, another short story of
his, The Double, was published in a journal.
A few weeks later, this became Dostoevsky’s
second novel, a mere five weeks after his
first one.
This one was not lauded nor loved and his
reputation almost immediately collapsed.
As a recent Guardian article put it, “Not
merely trashed, the book was denounced.
Dostoevsky became a bad joke.”
Partially due to the negative attention, Dostoevsky
began to suffer from health issues.
He fell into severe financial trouble, as
well.
This forced him to rely upon Belinsky and
his group of socialist friends for help.
On most Saturdays and Sundays, Dostoevsky
could be found at Mikhail Petrashevsky’s
residence, who was an intellect and an advocate
for utopian socialism.
They would talk, eat, discuss the trying times,
and denounce serfdom.
This weekend group became known as the Petrashevsky
Circle.
Besides Petrashevsky, Dostoevsky, and Belinsky,
the circle was made up of such individuals
as the writer Mikhail Saltykov-Shchedrin,
the poet Aleksey Pleshcheyev, and the painter
Taras Shevchenko – all well known Russian
creatives who happen to be socialist-leaning.
Besides serfdom, they also discussed socialist
politics, their opposition to the Tsar Nicholas
I, and read banned literature.
This all came to a halt when, on April 23,
1849, 35 members of the circle were arrested.
There was also a note sent to police officers
calling for Dostoevsky’s arrest by name.
It read,
" According to the supreme order of the Tsar,
I command you to arrest Junior-Lieutenant
and literary artist Fyodor Dostoevsky at four
o’clock in the morning… to put a seal
on all of his papers, manuscripts, and books,
and dispatch instantly all these materials,
together with Dostoevsky to the Third Section
of the Royal Police of His Majesty… if Dostoevsky
claims that certain documents belong to other
people, ignore these statements and seal those
documents as well."
The group was incarcerated in St. Peter and
Paul Fortress Prison, or simply known as “Fortress
Prison,” where the worst criminals were
kept.
After months in prison, they were convicted
of distributing letters with “abusive remarks
about the Orthodox Church and Government”
and conspiring to publish “anti-Government
propaganda.”
For this, they were sentenced to death by
firing squad.
On December 22nd, they were marched out blindfolded
to Semyonov Square in Saint Petersburg.
As preparations were made, every person was
prepared to die that day.
As Dostoevsky would later write to his brother,
"There the sentence of death was read to all
of us, we were told to kiss the cross, our
swords were broken over our heads, and our
last toilet was made.
Then three were tied to the pillar for execution.
I was the sixth.
Three at a time were called out; consequently,
I was in the second batch and no more than
a minute was left me to live."
In his novel, The Idiot, he also perhaps shed
some light on his thoughts while he had that
minute left to live:
"…But better if I tell you of another man
I met last year…this man was led out along
with others on to a scaffold and had his sentence
of death by shooting read out to him, for
political offenses…he was dying at 27, healthy
and strong…he says that nothing was more
terrible at that moment than the nagging thought:
“What if I didn’t have to die!…I would
turn every minute into an age, nothing would
be wasted, every minute would be accounted
for…"
As the squad pointed their guns at the three
tied to the posts (as noted, not Dostoevsky,
who was off to the side), the shout went out,
“Prepare to fire!” and, then, another
sound rang out – that of a drummer who had
been commanded to beat the “refuse,” meaning
stop the previous order.
The messenger had arrived with Tsar Nicholas’s
I new order.
“Long Live the Tsar” was yelled, blindfolds
were taken off, and the prisoners, including
Dostoevsky, had tears in their eyes.
They were saved, but this wasn’t a last
second show of mercy.
This pardon was actually agreed upon the day
before, but with the orders that it was to
be announced only at the last possible second.
Mock executions have been a frequent torture
technique meant to cause trauma, fear, and,
at times, gratitude to those who “saved”
them.
They have even been used in modern times as
well.
A recent ABC report stated that ISIS used
mock executions on American and Japanese hostages.
In 1979, during the Iranian hostage crisis,
those who worked at the American Embassy in
Tehran were subjected to mock executions.
The Chicago Tribune also reported that America’s
CIA may have staged mock executions in hopes
of getting alleged terrorists to talk in 2004.
Despite this reprieve, the prisoners didn’t
get off scot-free, far from it actually.
Dostoevsky, along with several of his fellow
prisoners, were sent to work camps in Siberia,
where they spent four years doing hard labor.
When Dostoevsky was released in 1854, he was
still required to serve in the Siberia Regiment
for a number of years.
But he also went back to writing, most likely
humbled.
In 1854, he published The House of the Dead,
a semi-autobiographical work about life in
a Siberian prison camp.
He continued to write and gain his literary
creditability back.
In 1864, Crime & Punishment was published,
a novel about a young student plotting to
kill a pawnbroker to take her riches and rid
the world of “worthless vermin.”
This was Dostoevsky’s most famous work.
And, of course, it wouldn’t have been written
and you’d likely never have heard of him
if the decision to pardon Fyodor Dostoevsky
hadn’t been made.
It would seem he really didn’t waste the
rest of his life.